[Music]
today President Trump made history with
a dramatic shift of US foreign policy in
the Middle East he forged ahead with his
decision to declare Jerusalem Israel's
capital despite objections from Arab
European and other world leaders and
even the Pope we cannot solve our
problems by making the same failed
assumptions and repeating the same
failed strategies of the past all
challenges demand new approaches I have
determined that it is time to officially
recognize Jerusalem as the capital of
Israel while previous presidents have
made this a major campaign promise they
failed to deliver today I am delivering
president Trump stress Israel's a
foreign I'm sorry a sovereign nation
with the right to determine its own
capital the president also ordered the
State Department to begin the process of
moving our embassy to Jerusalem from Tel
Aviv in an attempt to ease concerns mr.
Trump wanted pilot Palestinians to know
he still remains fully committed to
helping broker a peace deal I also want
to make one point very clear this
decision is not intended in any way to
reflect a departure from our strong
commitment to facilitate a lasting peace
agreement we want an agreement that is a
great deal for the Israelis and a great
deal for the Palestinians I intend to do
everything in my power to help forge
such an agreement so definitely a
historic day one I thought I'd go to you
first because you've covered this issue
for over many presidents the position of
the United States now firmly ensconced
in the promise that had been made for
many years that the United States would
make this recognition and finally today
it happened right but of course part of
that policy for the longest time Dana
has been a two-state solution that we
would in terms of final status with
regard to Jerusalem have that as part of
the negotiation
negotiation in the United States even
with people like Bill Clinton who were
all about moving the capital said I'm
sorry the embassy said very clearly that
the reason they didn't do it was to
preserve the United States as a fear and
you know well-regarded arbiter on both
sides by the Israelis and the
Palestinians so what we saw today was
sort of a pre-emptive move now you have
Jared Kushner supposedly out there
trying to make a deal of some kind we
haven't seen much evidence of any
progress but what we have seen now is
the president I think it's almost like a
businessman he says you know what let's
just shake it up let's put the
Palestinians on notice if you don't like
the way things are going well then you
better get back to the bargain but he
wasn't the only one Kimberly because the
crown prince will now King Salman of
Saudi Arabia called Abu Mazen of the
Palestinians and said this you know you
need to get on board with this and in
the president book I think recognizes
that in their capitals in the in these
different countries they have to say
what they're going to say for their
domestic audiences but this seems I
think to be okay with the Saudi Arabians
and possibly others for an anti Iran
alliance yes I think so and that's
really I think what is you know behind
this as well and in large measure but
this is something that the president has
been considering and contemplating for
some time there has been you know
tremendous support from the Israeli
community to do this and for the
president to make this move and you've
seen a very solid friendship and
alliance between Netanyahu and President
Trump that they work very well
cooperatively there's a lot of mutual
respect there which i think is a healthy
and good thing for the United States
going forward I take him at his word I
believe him when he says that he's going
to continue to try to you know broker a
deal and work this out but sometimes you
need to broker a deal with a show of
strength and a show of commitment and
like I said he's been saying he's gonna
do it and now in fact he has so
Jerusalem was always like that piece it
was going to be the final bargaining
chip but after several decades with
nothing ever happening then maybe this
actually is a way to get there and I
didn't hear the president say he was
against a two-state solution so maybe
this will actually push people to the
table I don't know you want to see a
picture of a Middle East expert
a blank space isn't unsolved there you
go thank you solvable Rubik's Cube and
we keep talking about this thing we as
if this is gonna upset some kind of
peace process in the Middle East there
this peace process has been upset in the
Middle East since I was a child you want
if you want a peace process Palestinians
stop killing Jews that's a start right
every time the destruction of Israel and
also all the Dems were for this Oh bomb
was word Hillary was for it Bill Clinton
is for Pelosi is Bill now in the evil
orange Republican is for it the media's
gonna say that this is gonna cause World
War 3 World War four World War five it's
no different than anything anybody else
has said the most important thing is
this check the change of address cards
because I didn't do that when I moved
and I don't get any of my cat fancy
issues no I'm not well neither are they
what is your take on the day's news well
he got Schumer and I think Romney and
Debbie wasserman-schultz
and Ted Cruz to all agree so I think
that's probably a pretty good deal right
now it was very symbolic we have a great
relationship with Israel our only real
partner democracy in the Middle East and
he fulfilled a campaign promise so I
think his supporters are gonna be happy
about that I think our NATO allies and
our Pacific partners have to look at
this and say this is the president of
States doing what he said he was going
to do and that has to make them feel
more comfortable and it's vintage Trump
he actually does what he says he's going
to do and then there's a bunch of
hysteria but the hysteria is not always
as bad as it seems like it's going to be
and I think he kind of relishes doing
things that other presents have said
they're gonna do or did or didn't do
whether it's the Keystone pipeline or
cornering North Korea or withdrawing
from bad trade deals or treaties or
something like that I think he enjoys
this but you know what Hamas says
they're gonna unleash hell and there's
going to be a Day of Rage isn't
terrorists oh you're always raging if
you're a terrorist so I don't really see
that much happening the United States
and Israel will be prepared now I want
to get your take one on
because they are Turkey is a part of
NATO but the president there came out
very strongly against it and said
there'll be fire and fury basically a
take on my president trumpet said about
North Korea
and then you had this I will just read
it for you Abbas said these condemned
and unacceptable measures are a
deliberate undermining of all efforts
exerted to achieve peace and represent a
declaration in the United States
withdrawal from undertaking the role it
has played over the past decades in
sponsoring the peace process so it could
end up that the Palestinians should have
taken the deals that were on the table
in the last couple of decades well I
think that's what President Crump must
be thinking again you shake it up but
just to go back to what you were saying
Turkey is our ally you have the Turkish
spokesmen saying this is a red line for
the Muslims around the world but
specifically in the Middle East and so
you know when you think about what's
different here it's not that the the
thought isn't isn't is anything
radically shifting from what Democrats
and Republicans have said in the past
the difference is that you do it as
separate unilateral action apart from
any larger negotiation and so people are
saying well what is this signal what
does this mean this week and I was out
at the Reagan Library and they had a
defense forum and so you had people like
Leon Panetta Michele Flournoy Mike
Pompeo from CIA even you know former
Secretary of State Shultz and what
they're saying is look Iran and Russia
are moving into a power vacuum in the
Middle East you know how you have Russia
now a major ally of Syria and others and
we hear lots of talk from President
Trump about you know we're going to be
more emphatic we're going to be more
involved but there's nothing on the
ground there's no actual policy and so
he makes this move that I think does
please some part of his evangelical base
may even some of the Orthodox Jewish
community in this country which votes
Republican but in terms of Israel I
don't know that all Israelis are in
support of this because what they want
is more security for their car they were
going to be attacked regardless I would
I do want to bring up one thing that
might get Gregg going this is the Pope I
cannot remain silent about my deep
concern for the situation that has
developed in recent days and at the same
time I wish to make a heartfelt appeal
to ensure that everyone is committed to
respecting the status quo of the city in
accordance with a with the relevant
resolutions of the United Nations but
everybody spoke out before the president
actually gave a speech because he said
that he's okay with talking about the
boundaries as they were discussed for
East Jerusalem wait I'm trying to
maintain a level of politeness about the
Pope you knew this was going to set me
off you did this on purpose
look this is an ongoing conflict over a
religious claim over a city so it's like
three teams arguing over own field
advantage
all right I don't play this sport so I
don't have to listen to what the Pope
says I don't care about what the Pope
says I don't think he helps it in this
situation I think you should just stay
out of it
you know I can't I can barely control
myself when he talks about climate
change so I think I don't want to look I
don't want to talk about the Pope the
Pope should but out of the an opinion we
have a right to respond to that opinion
of course yeah but there's a lot of
opinion at this so it's it's Hamas it's
the United Nations the Turks the
Palestinians the Germans I mean gosh but
do you think it's possible kimberley
what should after the short of this
announcement sure and people have time
if things don't become fire in fury in
the Middle East that perhaps other
nations will follow our lead and in fact
move their embassies to Jerusalem as
well yes I think there always has to be
a trailblazer and president Trump has
always been comfortable with doing that
you know in his life historically and
throughout his business you know career
I think again this was a bold and
decisive it's a historic moment and you
know Israel is a sovereign state and
they have every right to be able to
decide and choose where their capitalism
where they want embassies and to be so I
think the United States is respecting
their sovereignty and their decision on
their choice and honoring that one said
that there's a power vacuum in the
Middle East and Iran's now empowered I
think that's probably because President
Obama gave them trillions of dollars and
withdrew precipitously from Iraq
so I also
think that this Spurs the Mideast peace
process whatever that means Greg because
everything they did before by putting
this on the table the Jerusalem issue
with everything else in the negotiation
hadn't worked so I think what the
president is doing is saying let's
trying something different okay in your
words shake it up and this makes
everybody re-engage makes both
stakeholders come back to the table with
a little more urgency and I think that's
good I think they're sequencing yeah
right so they make this announcement
then today somebody on background from
the White House said that they expect
within the next 12 to 14 months to have
more of a fleshed out plan so then you
actually have some time for it to take
hold so I think then you have to think
of it in terms of just he said symbolic
and I think that while purely said this
is a historic day I think of it as
symbolic and a political gesture because
we're not actually moving the embassy
anytime soon he's going to sign another
waiver that says the embassy will remain
in Tel Aviv and then then say Oh what
next months right every six months you
keep doing it he said or apparently I
think this is what the president's aides
said today according to the news well
just take some time that it will take
years before they can even think about
it Jesse because they got to build it
they got to find a contractor land